تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو للمعتمر لمعتمر يحمل والدته فوق
اكتافه اثناء الطواف لاداء مناسك العمره
وسط فرحه تغمر الام في الوقت الذي سطر
ناشط التواصل الاجتماعي اروع العبارات في
بر الوالدين
[موسيقى]
ونتابع ايضا من الحرم المكي حيث وثق مقطع
فيديو متداول فرحه معتمره بعدما سمح لها
رجال الامن بالوصول الى الحجر الاسود
وتقبيله
[موسيقى]
في مشهد صادم وتقى مقطع فيديو لاحد
المسعفين وهو يسرق 60 الف جنيه استرليني
من منزل سيده مسنه في بريطانيا بعد ان
فارقت الحياه بلحظات قبل ان يعيد المال
عندما انتبه لوجود كاميرا مراقبه
[موسيقى]
تعرض الرئيس الفرنسي لموقف محرج داخل
اورقه القصر الرئاسي الصيني اثناء التقاط
صوره الرسميه بجانب الرئيس الصيني حيث وضع
يده في جيبه لكن يبدو ان احدهم تدخل وطلب
منه اخراجها لنتابع
[موسيقى]
في لفته انسانيه مؤثره وتقى مقطع فيديو
متداول على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لمسلم
المغربي يساعد شخصا مبثورا الساق على دفع
عربته بالمغرب نشاهد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات